on a appris on a appris la nouvelle nous
on était pas avec Gims on était en on
était en tournée et on a après la
nouvelle en sortant de scène donc on
sortait de scène et les premières
phrases qu'on nous a dit c'est
il y a eu un séisme un gros séisme au
Maroc et on n'arrive plus à avoir les
enfants c'est dire qu'on est sorti de
scène sur ça
nos enfants
ils étaient au Maroc c'était un
Marrakech et donc on n'arrivait pas on
n'arrivait pas à les joindre et là où on
était on n'avait pas de réseau ça veut
dire qu'on a on appelle ça pleure au
téléphone après ça coupe c'est à dire
que c'était une angoisse de au moins 40
45 minutes avant de retrouver le
de retrouver le réseau et de pouvoir
entendre les explications et
donc on a pris on a pris le premier
avion on est on est allé on est retourné
à la maison et c'est là qu'on a vu les
dégâts on a vu tout ce qui se passait on
a vu on a vu les gens à la rue les gens
qui dormaient dehors parce que parce que
ils ont peur justement de retourner de
retourner chez eux des gens qui qui
recherchent encore
les portées disparus des gens de leur
famille etc toutes mes pensées on verra
vers les les familles qui ont perdu des
proches on a essayé de se mobiliser un
petit peu pour on voit les dons de sang
la solidarité qui se met en place vous
en êtes bien sûr exactement vous avez
fait rentrer vos enfants votre famille
il voulait pas rentrer ils veulent pas
ils veulent pas rentrer ils veulent
rester ils veulent rester ils veulent
retourner à l'école ils veulent en fait
ils ont envie de continuer de vivre et
j'ai pas envie de leur casser ça non
plus bien évidemment j'ai j'ai toujours
cette peur et cette crainte mais bon
nous on
je suis quelqu'un de très croyant et
c'est Dieu qui décide dans tous les cas
que ce soit en France ou que ce soit au
Maroc s'il a s'il a décidé que ça devait
se passer comme ça ça se passera comme
ça donc je les ai laissés au Maroc avec
avec leur maman avec leurs cousins les
enfants de de Gims etc et continue leur
vie